Thanks for having me.
It's really great to be here at Google.
I'm always curious as to what
Google is up to. So maybe, uh,
I get to ask you guys questions
after the talk. Um, it's,
uh, it's about this detection
that I, that I want to talk today.
I don't know if people heard
on February 11th, 2016, uh,
just this year there was an announcement
made about an otherwise very obscure
experiment nobody had
heard of before. And, uh,
and suddenly it was on the cover of
all the newspapers internationally.
It was reported everywhere, a
radio and television that, uh,
this obscure experiment had announced
the discovery of the century,
the first human procured
recordings of gravitational waves.
Did you hear this? And, um,
and gravitational waves were cited
as ripples in the shape of spacetime.
That's what everyone always says.
They're ripples in the shape of space
time there literally a squeezing and
stretching of space.
The recording that was captured was of
the collision of two black holes that
rang the space and time around them,
like mallets on a drum ringing
the drama of space time.
Those waves in the shape of space emanated
out traveling at the speed of light,
although they are not light, which I
think is very important distinction.
I'll try to emphasize and they took a
1.3 billion year journey before sloshing
over the earth and
striking this experiment.
Did you hear the gravitational
waves? Okay, we're going to listen.
So anyway. Yeah, that's loud. That's good.
That was good.
That's okay.
So that sound,
uh,
was not so loud.
They were actually listening to the
detector and the Control Room when they're
struck and it was too quiet to hear
would actually probably have been loud
enough to hear by the human ear through
the speaker system in the control room.
But um,
but it happens so fast that the operators
in the control room couldn't have,
couldn't have parsed it really.
It happened too fast.
But I want to discuss why we're
talking about this as sound. Really.
That's the part I want to emphasize.
I know people have heard this,
they've heard the recording,
they saw the discovery in the papers,
but I think that people are still
quite unsure what it all means,
why it's a sound, why it isn't a
picture and what this discovery means.
So that's kind of what I want to pick
apart today before we do the Q and a.
Um, here is, uh,
the universe sort of as we know it.
This is from the Sloan digital sky survey.
Everything, every object in this
survey has been observed. These are,
this is not a cartoon. These
are real observations. Uh,
those objects are all galaxies.
So each galaxy has 100 billion stars more.
And um,
and there are 100 billion galaxies
in the observable universe.
As many galaxies as there are
stars in the Milky Way. And,
and it just goes on and on forever.
Every one of these being an entire galaxy.
Nope. So much of what we
know about the universe,
almost everything that we know about
the universe comes to us from light,
from things like telescopes, right? We
sit on this planet for the most part.
Occasionally we put something in
orbit around the earth or the sun,
but we just from the confines
of this rocky planet,
basically we collect light and
take pictures of the sky. And A,
we've amassed this incredible story that
the universe is 13.8 billion years old,
that it's full of galaxies, that we
are not at the center of the universe,
that the universe expands.
Um,
that there was a big bang
13.8 billion years ago.
We know that there are black holes,
maybe, uh, hundreds of thousands,
maybe millions in every galaxy. We think
there are supermassive black holes,
millions or billions of times the mass
of the sun and their centers are these
galaxies. We know that there's dark
matter matter that we can't see,
but we only indirectly see its
effects and dark energy. Um,
but what else is out there
is sort of the question.
If we know that there's
dark matter and dark energy,
are there other dark things
that we simply can't see?
And black holes are an example of
dark things that usually we can't see.
So I'm here is uh, astronomical
image. Again, this is not a cartoon.
This is a real image of a galaxy
and the direction of Hercules,
the constellation Hercules'.
It's an entire galaxy,
hundreds of billions of stars.
It's actually a very big galaxy.
It's bigger than that in the center is
a supermassive black hole we suspect.
And why do we suspect it?
Because we see these huge jets coming
out of the galaxy that are powered by
material being taken down by the black
hole and spat out before it falls in.
People often ask me, how did the material
get out from inside the black hole?
Nothing can escape a black hole. They, it
doesn't come from inside the black hole.
It actually never makes it inside.
It gets shot out along these tremendous
jets and those jets are millions of
light years across.
And we see them from this great distance
and that's how we figured out black
holes are out there. But essentially, uh,
black holes should be
invisible to us usually.
So there's lots of black holes out there
that we simply couldn't see that are
too dark to possibly see. And that's
where the gravitational waves come in.
So gravitational waves are a
way of observing the universe,
but not through light.
The gravitational wave observatory that
made that discovery is not a telescope
of any kind.
It doesn't take pictures of the sky.
It actually makes recording of the
ringing of the shape of space time.
So you want to try to get into the answer.
So let's try to get into that stuff.
Um, it was interesting that all
of this does come from Einstein's.
So a lot of people were
saying very excitedly, um,
this was the confirmation of
Einstein's theory of relativity,
but nobody was that surprised about this
particular conformation in some sense.
Uh, it was much more the fact
that it could even be done at all.
So here's an example of spacetime. You
know, if we're in this space of this room,
we don't see curves in space time.
This is Einstein's theory.
Einstein's theory is that space time is
curved in response to mass and energy.
But we can't see these curves.
If you were to float in empty space and
you were to like throw objects and empty
space, they would trace
straight lines, right?
If you're an astronaut and you're far
from the earth and you can't see any stars
and you were to just throw,
I don't know what,
what astronauts have their hands on, I
don't know, a bolt, something, a tool,
it would travel in a straight line,
right?
So if I imagined painting those
curves and space time, uh,
I would imagine painting a
straight line grid. Okay.
This is a way to give you an explanation
of what curved space. I mean,
intuition for what it's
like Einstein's theory says,
if I put a big mass in that space time,
like a star,
it will curve the shape of space around
it. And you already know that to be true.
If I take this clicker and I throw it,
you know,
it's not going to travel
in a straight line, right?
It's definitely going to trace an arc
and fall to the, to the earth. And, uh,
if we could paint all the paths that
I could imagine of throwing probes,
you could actually paint the curved
space time around it. And so intuitively,
uh, it's actually, it seems
like such a huge leap,
but yet intuitively we all know it's true.
We live in a space time where things do
not travel on straight lines and those
paths that things travel
along when they're free and
wait lists like this would
be if I let it drop or like
it would be if I through it.
Those are the curves in spacetime. So
an Einstein proposes a theory, you know,
it takes him forever. He really
struggles, uh, with the mathematics of,
of general relativity.
But when he comes up with the theory,
the first thing he turns to, um, it's
the topic of gravitational waves.
And, um, and here's the reason why.
If space time is curved by heavy masses,
then if those masters move,
the curves have to move and
adjust to follow it around.
Surely if the sun were to go
halfway across the universe,
the curves it creates around,
it must also move.
And those are the gravitational waves.
What happens is the curves
in space actually have to
move and adjust slower than
the speed of light or at
the speed of light. In this
case, because no information,
not even gravitational information
can go faster than the speed of light.
So these waves curve and adjust and
follow the mass and then wave outward
throughout space.
Now,
Einstein many times said
gravitational waves are real.
They're not real. They're
real. They're not real.
Over decades he was changing his
mind and writing different papers.
Sometimes he would write a paper that
said gravitational waves are not real.
And between acceptance of the
paper for publication and print,
he would write it saying, which one
did I say? Not that they are okay.
So he changed his mind. Uh, many
times. This is not simple stuff.
So this is from 1915,
1916 in the 30s,
people are still arguing of gravitational
waves are real. Um, in some people,
even in the 60s,
in the early seventies,
very visionary people that Kip
Thorne start to become convinced that
gravitational waves are real.
Um,
and that somehow they're
fundamental to our whole, uh,
theory of gravity hanging together.
Um,
this is a computer simulation now modern
times of two black holes colliding and
it's a very formal mathematical,
a system based in relativity.
This problem even on a computer
since you guys like to code a lot,
we'll appreciate,
was so hard.
Even though we know Einstein's
theory of curved space time,
we can write the equations down,
we can plug them into a computer.
It doesn't just run. It was, it was a
numerical problem that seemed insoluble.
And that's because of gravity
is very nonlinear. As a space,
time would curve and change
with the two black holes.
It would feed back into itself in such
a complicated way that they couldn't get
the codes to run. It took 30
years, three decades for them to,
to write the codes properly, um,
and solve that numerical problems.
So here is a beautiful, uh, uh,
visualization of that one
of the numerical solutions.
It shows two black holes.
They've helpfully painted the curves in
space time around at kind of contours.
If you can see the red coming out,
those are the gravitational waves
emitting as two black holes,
Bang on the drum ringing,
space time,
sending the waves outward at the speed
of light. The two black holes collide.
They make a bigger black hole,
which just settles down to this
perfect shape and goes quiet.
And that's the prediction.
This prediction has already I,
this must be this many years old, this,
this simulation may be 10 years old.
And um,
and it's an incredibly accurate prediction
of what the gravitational waves,
uh,
would sound like.
They would travel through the universe
getting quieter and quieter, um,
until it hit the earth. This is, um,
I'm going to show you a
much less sophisticated a
simulation that's based more
an analytical calculations. I'm going to
show you the orbits of two black holes.
I'm not going to show the,
the contours of the space,
but we're going to listen to them.
Okay?
So this is what it would sound like if
you could record the ringing shape of
drum. So one of the black hole
paths is yellow, one is red,
and they're going to start
to spiral in together.
So these two black holes are equal in
mass. Just why they're both moving.
One's not heavier than the other,
so they're both whirling around
and as they get closer together,
you can hear the frequency goes up
and eventually they're going to merge.
So you heard that Chirp and that's a
lot like the Chirp in the actual signal.
You see how similar,
that's the,
what's called the trip is when it sweeps
up and frequency as they collide. Now,
even now, you sort of maybe have a
better intuition of what the waves are,
but why are they sound?
If you were an astronaut floating
nearby those two black holes colliding,
you would not be able to see them, but
it could wring your eardrum. I mean, I,
you know, I always say that I'm not,
uh, I don't know anatomy that well.
So,
um,
I have talked to people who study the ear
in detail and they say it's plausible.
You know, I've never tried to do the
experiment floating near a black hole,
but um, but you, if you heard that you'd
like want to get out of there. If you're,
if you're floating near darkness
and you hear this chirping up,
it's like time to scoot.
Um,
so technically it is very much like sound.
It's not just a weak analogy. You know,
I can take any kind of light waves
and translate them into sound.
That's not what's happening.
This is not light.
It's literally vibrations on the drum.
And so it's like almost like having
an electric guitar where you pluck the
string and it makes no sound
until you amplify it, right?
Until you record the shape of
the string and you amplify it.
That's kind of what this instrument does.
It records the shape of the ringing.
John, we'll talk about that
more and it plays it back, um,
as sound.
Here's another pair of black holes.
One is much heavier,
so it's orbit is in yellow at hardly
moves because it's 10 times heavier than
the other. Um, the other moves much more.
You can see the orbits of
black holes are pretty crazy.
They're not like solar system orbits.
When they get close together,
they get pretty wild. And you can
hear the difference between these,
this one and the previous one,
how it gets quiet and then louder.
So we can hear that the whole
systems moving like this,
we can hear that they're
not on circular orbits.
We can even hear that they're
spinning if you know how to listen.
Okay.
And then they emerge.
But it's still chirps that Cerp is a real
characteristic of all these black call
systems. I'm sorry, I did a
touch the volume. Okay, wait,
before I do that,
let me go back for a second.
At the time that people decided to build
this instrument Lygo so the experiment,
this obscure experiment no one had
ever heard of that made this detection.
It's called Lego. It's the interferometer
gravitational wave observatory.
Um, it actually made the
detection in September,
September 14th, 2015. Uh, they
didn't announce it until February,
but it made the detection in September.
This experiment was dreamed up in the, uh,
late sixties.
And in a sort of started
to spread different ideas.
We're spreading, um, about
trying to do something like this.
But one of the original
architects was Ray Weiss.
He was a young professor at Mit.
He didn't understand the general
theory of relativity. He, uh,
was trying to teach it because MIT said,
you're running a gravity research program,
you should teach general relativity.
And he says, I couldn't tell them I
didn't know general relativity. Right.
So he starts to teach this
class. He says, I was bumbling,
but the students didn't walk out.
And the reason they didn't walk out,
it's cause he was dreaming up ways to
actually do experiments with the theory.
And that's when he dreamt up this idea.
Look, if there are gravitational waves,
he thought and they come across the earth,
then things will Bob on the
wave by the time they get here.
If I could suspend
mirrors very delicately,
they would sort of Bob as the wave past.
And if I could keep track of the
distance between those mirrors,
I would know if they hadn't
moved slightly apart and in,
and I could record the
shape of the ringing drum.
So if you could time had
extremely accurate clocks,
you would be able to do that
with what we call just one arm,
just to mirrors in a vacuum.
So the laser light doesn't get scattered
and shine the laser light between the
mirrors and with a very precise clock,
you could keep track of
where those mirrors are.
We don't have such precise clocks.
So instead he thinks of an interferometer,
which is two arms in an l shape and you'll
see the lego instruments in a second.
Um, and the light comes back and goes
down the two arms and comes back.
And if it traveled the same
distance in both directions,
then the light would interfere perfectly
and for travel different distances,
then it would interfere imperfectly.
And the waves would create
what's called a fringe pattern.
And so it's a much simpler detection to
look at the fringe pattern than it is to
try to use a clock.
And a,
he started building this machine.
It was 1.5 meters.
He was building in a place
called the plywood palace.
It was this ramshackle structure that
was thrown up during World War II and it
was supposed to be torn down
and they didn't tear it down.
It's supposed to last for 10 years.
It was,
it wasn't torn down for another 50 years.
And you know,
they used to punch holes in the ceiling
and break the pipes and they would
literally perform experiments and
go right through several stories.
And it was a crazy place.
Nine Nobel prizes came out of the
plywood palace and it was almost the
crappiness of the structure that
allowed them right to just be free to
experiment. He describes that
when he began these experiments,
everybody thought he was crazy. First
of all, they said it will never work.
Technologically.
It's impossible,
which are trying to do because by the
time the gravitational waves get here,
they're, uh, variations in distance, uh,
that we expect it to affect is a billionth
of a trillionth of the length of your
machine. Okay. A billionth of a
trillionth of the length of your machine.
So a 1.5 meter machine
isn't going to get anything.
One of his colleagues from Mit said,
uh,
you couldn't even record
the sun exploding.
I could look out the window and
do better, you know, and um,
and eventually he ran out of funding.
His grants were turned down and then
he found out after he had been declined
from his grants and people
started telling them,
you're not going to get tenure
and you're not going to succeed.
He found out that a German group,
which had read his grant to review it
for the National Science Foundation had
started to build these instruments,
but bigger and better. Okay.
So there he is in this ramshackle
structure with no money.
People are against them. They don't even
believe gravitational waves are real.
They certainly don't think black holes
are we all at this stage and time and um,
and he's about to lose out, right? He's,
he's about to lose out. And he says,
then what happened is I met Kip,
Kip Thorne.
Kip Thorne is the iconic astrophysicist
from your part of the world.
He's a caltech professor. Um, very
theoretical, very brilliant man.
And, um, and they go on this
campaign together. Okay.
So skipping ahead a bit.
50 years later,
800 people invested in the experiment.
Uh,
nearly a billion dollars.
Two instruments that each
spanned four kilometers, uh,
make the detection of the century and
they, and it's not an easy 50 years,
it's an arduous 50 years.
Here is the full scale detector.
This is an instrument in Hanford.
These are the arms.
The mirrors are suspended at the ends of
these arms and the laser light travels
along this vacuum.
So that's the site and Louisiana.
And you can tell cause it's swampy,
there are alligators and bass and
things like that and the swamps. Um,
and uh, so here we're going to see the
laser light. This part is a cartoon.
Obviously you can't go inside
the beam. Um, but those,
that vacuum,
so the wasn't built until 1998.
It has stayed in a vacuum.
It's two of the largest holes in the
earth's atmosphere, um, ever made.
And these are the chambers of the corner
stations where the mirrors are and the
beam splitters and all of
the optical components.
But the rest of it's just vacuum and
laser light. So if that vacuum is broken,
one of the heads lead scientists
told me we'd all go home.
It would all be over a lot of
the expenses and keeping that,
that vacuum alive or,
or building it in the first place.
There's the physical difference between
the two sites and they put them as far
apart so that there's not the
possibility of coincidence, false alarms.
And they're basically recording.
So we imagine some ripple in the
shape of space comes from far away.
It rings the instruments, they record
it, and they literally play it back.
A sound in the control room.
You can listen to the detector and the
control room and it's constantly noisy
and humming to hear earthquakes in China,
they hear wins from the Gulf.
They have all kinds of seismic activity.
Um, planes, the moon, the sun, tides,
everything rings. This
machine, it's very noisy,
but the billionth of a trillionth
of an arm, a four kilometer arm,
amounts to tiny variations in distance,
less than a 10000th of the width of a
proton. And that's what they recorded.
Just quite remarkable. This is a sound
of the instrument and the control room.
This is the noise. This is what it
sounds like. Most of them, it's the
time. You can hear different
modes in that. Okay,
so this is what happened
on September 14th.
There's ray himself 50 years later is
still at the sites working on the machine.
He was there on September 13th,
um,
looking for radio interference and they
were not ready to, to run detections.
The machines were operational.
They were ready with some
of the algorithms weren't
ready for the data analysis
and they were, um, they were still
doing what the Kulin engineering run,
which is you run tasks and you interrupt
the machine and you see how it responds
to certain vibrations, trucks
breaking, banging on it with hammers,
whatever they're doing. Ray,
luckily his wife says, come home.
So he puts down his tools and he goes
home in the middle of the night on
September 14th and Louisiana and
the middle of the night in uh,
Hanford Washington,
where the other instrument is the,
the young scientists that the people
working on the sites and the graduate
students there,
they're running their tests,
they're taking the machine on and offline.
They finally decide they've had enough.
It's two eight and they go home.
4:50 AM coming from the southern sky
after a 1.3 billion year journey.
Within a span of an hour of them leaving
the instrument in observing mode,
it strikes Louisiana
10 milliseconds later,
maybe a little less at cruises across
the continent and rings the Hanford
machine. And it's this spectacularly
loud beautiful of them.
And this is what it was. If you
pointed a telescope, this is not,
this is a computer simulation,
not a picture, not a movie.
We couldn't possibly
see it with a telescope,
but this is what it would look like.
If you could look at the lending of
the light behind the two black holes.
One was about 29 times a mass.
This on one was 36.
I think they're pretty big black holes.
They're orbiting each other and the final
seconds of their life together there,
this is vastly slowed down.
They're going at a half,
2.7 of the speed of light. Do you guys
want to see that again? It's pretty great.
Let's see that again.
They're going about a half the
speed of light up to almost 0.7.
The speed of light,
like 70% of the speed of light there are
about 200 kilometers across roughly in
size. And um, and all we caught
was the last four orbits.
That was the only part that was allowed
enough to detect the event horizons are
empty space.
These are just holes in space time,
the event horizons touch and coalesce
and make a bigger black hole.
You can see how deformed it looks and
eventually that bigger black hole rings
down and becomes quiet and we'll
hear will hear it again in a second.
So it's quite spectacular how distorted
they start to look and then they wobble
together and they form a one quiet,
spinning black hole.
You can't even tell that
black hole spinning.
So here's what happened at the
observatories 1.3 billion years later.
So that's what they hear.
And again, it's slowed down.
They only hear it once.
Of course,
it's just for a fact that they
like to repeat it. They had a half,
they had 200 milliseconds,
a fifth of a second.
So you got to play it four times to
get any kind of, um, feeling out of it.
So it took them a months
to analyze the data.
But that morning and Europe,
people wake up and they see this candidate
event and the data and there starts
to become a lot of chatter.
People start talking about it.
People wake up eventually,
8:00 AM a few hours after it happened
in the east coast and eventually in
Hanford, and they start to hear all
this chatter and everyone's incredulous.
Somebody said, you know, we just
turn the thing on. There's no way.
People told me it wouldn't be until 2018
that the first detection was made and
everybody told me it wouldn't be black
holes except for Kip Thorne. Okay.
Kip always said it's going
to be black holes first. Um,
and Ronna who's one of the
experiment list said, um,
this time we're going to detect
something. And I said, Ronna,
how can you be so sure? And he said, I
always say that I see ahead every run. Um,
and uh,
and he said it didn't mean he didn't even
look at the data for a day because he
was so incredulous. He thought, this
is ridiculous. It's not real. And, uh,
they worried that it had
been intentionally injected
into the data as a false
signal, which is something that the
experimentalists do on purpose to test the
experiment. They inject false signals
into the data. So everyone thought,
Oh God, it's a blind injection.
This is ridiculous. Oh, Mike Landry,
lead scientist at Hanford
said he sat down that morning.
He was kind of pissed off at the
team of injector as he's like,
what are you guys doing? We're not
ready for this yet. He sends down,
he sits down next to the guy and says,
are we going to phase of blind injection?
And the guy, he was like,
no. And he starts to ask,
he's not allowed to ask,
did you do a blind injection of two
black holes colliding? You know,
but he can sort of ask,
are we in a phase?
And He permutes the question until
few times and he keeps getting no.
And finally he says,
are we in a phase of injections
of any kind anywhere?
And the Guy Says No. And he says, I
got cold is what he told me. He said,
I just went cold.
So on the telecomm that day,
everyone's talking and many people are
raising the possibility that supply and
injection. And somewhere in
the phone call, Mike says,
I don't know how many people are on the
line. Many, many voices on the line.
This is an 800 person international
collaboration. Mike says,
it's not a blind injection. Someone
else says, sorry, Mike, you know,
can you say that again? And that's when
they started to take it seriously. Um,
which is pretty remarkable,
pretty, pretty fortunate that, uh,
it just shows that quitting and going
home and be a very effective technique.
So here, just to wrap up is another
view of our universe. Again,
this is not a cartoon.
This is real data from the Hubble.
Everything you're seeing here is,
um, is a, is an entire galaxy.
And again,
we can see a lot in the universe,
but we know that all the
light that we receive,
that the constituents of the universe
that are luminous is less than a 5% of
what the universe has in it.
Everything else is dark, dark energy,
dark matter.
Um,
among that 5% black holes were
actually part of that small 5%,
but it just means that the universe is
a vast amount of dark phenomena that we
will never see with telescopes that
we hope we could only hope to record,
uh, with something like a
gravitational wave observatory.
So as the universe expands and
eventually it gets darker, um,
the universe will also go quiet.
But in the meantime,
what we're really hoping for from these
experiments is that they'll detect
things we haven't even thought of before.
Not just black holes colliding,
neutron stars, supernova. These are
all game for the gravitational wave.
Observatory is a neutron,
stars are stars that didn't quite become
black holes that died and collapsed,
but conformed black holes.
We expect to be able to record a whole
range as long as it's kind of cataclysmic,
big astrophysical phenomena.
But I think the real hope is that
we'll detect something we've never even
thought of before. Okay. Thank
you. I'd love to take questions
people.
Hi there.
I was curious how you were able to locate
the event in three dimensional space
with two and for Rongeurs.
Um, it's not easy. So, uh,
I always liken this to um,
listening for your phone.
If you don't know where your phone is
and it's ringing and you can't see it,
it's really hard to find your phone.
So you need two ears for any
kind of location ability. Um,
and to interferometer is helps.
If you only had one,
you would be saying it's
Kinda from over there,
like a whole huge patch of the sky.
With two you can do better.
Um,
but it's not great.
And so the future is expecting many
more interferometer as a whole network.
On the earth that there's
going to be an underground, uh,
instrument built in Japan.
There's one in Italy that's almost online.
It's not as sensitive,
but it will really help with location.
There might be one in India, which
is going forward. So, um, so that's,
that's gonna help a lot.
Yes. Hi. All right, so many questions.
I don't know where to begin.
Let me ask this one.
Um,
we know electromagnetic radiation
attenuates with distance. Yes.
That's true of
gravitational waves as well.
Yeah. It, um, it gets
quieter with distance.
So the closer you are, the louder
the event would be. Definitely. And,
um, also, uh, I should point out
that this was the most energy,
most powerful event we've had since the
big bang that we've detected since the
big bang.
Uh,
the power that came out was many billions
and trillions of times the power that
comes out of the Sun and light. Uh, so
this is an incredibly powerful event,
yet it's very quiet.
So if you blew up a nuclear,
a nuclear bomb, you would not be able to
measure the gravitational waves from it.
It would be totally insignificant.
Yes.
So you got this event,
uh,
within a few hours of turn
the instrumental on and
now it's been on for half a
year.
Have you gotten many more?
Okay,
well I have to clarify that I'm totally
theoretical physicist so I don't build
the machine.
And part of what happened
is that I started following
so closely this experiment
out of fascination because it was other,
I do a lot of theoretical work about
the colliding black holes in the
predictions,
but the idea that anybody would take
it seriously enough to try to build a
machine just seemed ridiculous
to me, you know? And um,
and so I am technically
not supposed to be privy
to the t detections.
They did tell me though,
I think I was the only person that was
officially told of the detection before
the formal announcement in February 11th.
And I can tell you that in that
February Lambath announcement,
they did talk about another bump,
right?
Another signal that looks like, uh,
sounds like two colliding black holes,
but it was nowhere near loud enough or
significant enough for them to have made
a claim of a first detection with
that. Um, it came, it came a later,
but it was significant enough that
it's helping them assess how often this
happens.
And um,
and so it looks like there's going
to be a lot of black hole black hole
collisions and the machine is down
right now. It's been down since January.
It was not at advanced capability.
It was at,
it was better than the previous
generations and machines, but that's also,
I nobody really expected it to
do anything. Uh, right away it's,
it still needs to become more sensitive
by at least a factor of three or four.
So they take it down and they tweak it
and they work on it and they're going to
bring it back up probably late
summer. And when we expect, yes,
we fully expect maybe monthly we're going
to be hearing things like black hole
collisions. We don't know if we're
going to hear anything else. Yes.
Related to the attenuation.
So if
you take a bowl of water and you tap it,
you'll see your waves and they will
still after a little while. So is right.
Is there a analog of
viscosity in space time?
Not really. It's
interesting, nor for light.
So we still receive light from the
big bang that's been traveling too,
as for 13.8 billion years.
It's, it's colder, right?
It's redder than when it was created.
That has to do with the expansion of the
universe. But light never tires, right?
Light never slows down like what you're
describing and there's no friction.
Okay. And in the same way, there's
really not for gravitational waves.
They travel at the speed of light
and they also never tire or,
or slow down. Um, if, uh,
it's a way that we say that all particles
that are massless travel at the speed
of light. So you know, the wave
particle duality for light waves,
there's a quantum particle
called the photon.
And as long as that photon is massless,
it will travel at the speed of light.
If it has any mass, then yes, it will
slow down and stop. And the Graviton,
which is the particle,
uh,
analog or the particle compliment to the
gravitational wave is massless as far
as we understand. If it does have some
small mass and we're wrong about that,
then maybe they would eventually slow
down and stop and there would not be
traveling at the speed of light.
MMM.
Any other questions? Okay, please.
You just a quick phone him
up to a microphone real
quick. Fall into that. Yeah.
We've not detected anything
like I'd grab a time, right?
No, it's way too hard.
So gravity is so weak.
We're nowhere near the regime
of probing the quantum scale.
What would the, I mean, we kind
of understand the, you know,
a Photon, you know, how, how waves,
electromagnetic waves and photons
can, can be, you know, convert. Yeah.
Back and forth between each other.
Theoretically.
What would the gravitational waves that
they detected look like for gravitons?
Um,
you mean if we could probe the
quantum level or, yeah, so,
so the light in this room is made up of
so many photons that it's really hard to
notice the particulate nature
of it. Um, and similarly,
the gravitational waves are made up of
so many gravitons that it's impossible to
notice.
The particulate nature of it.
We haven't really very well thought of
an experiment where we could do that.
And probably the energy scale you'd
have to get to is something like,
uh,
um,
let's see a million times the
large hadron collider energy,
something like that. So it's, it, it's
not an ambition of the near future.
I mean this was pretty crazy, but
that would be really crazy. Yes.
Ah, so it sounded like, I'm not
sure if I understood correctly,
but part of the reason your software
was able to detect this event and notify
you guys cause you kind of knew
what you were listening for,
you kind of had a prediction
for what it would sound like.
Yeah, correct. Well, that
is correct. A lot of,
one of the difficulties in
this experiment is that, uh,
the sound will often be quieter
than the noise. And so, um,
they'll have to sometimes
run the predictions, uh,
especially the numerical ones in through
the data and filter it that way and
pluck it out. But this one
was so loud, it's just you.
It's just right above the noise.
It's actually really loud.
So it's not as reliant on that as,
uh,
as we fully expected things to be.
So is it that you guys are actually just
writing straight up anomaly detection
and that's what you want to use to like
possibly detect other events in the
future? Yeah, there's, there's,
there's three or four different
teams within the collaboration that,
that use different models to pluck
out different kinds of signals,
summer bursts signals.
Some are these what we call compact
binary coalescence things like black holes
and neutron stars and
white dwarves. Um, and uh,
and some stochastic which
just, you know, noisier.
So there's all of these different
algorithms that people, right.
But I don't think anyone expected
the first signal we detect to be just
noticeably loud. Yeah,
sure. It was just fast.
If it had been slower, um, I think they
would have heard it in the control room.
It was that loud.
What is the range of events that you
expect to be able to detect with Lego?
I understand their potential.
He's like solar system scale and
barometers for rejecting more,
less energetic events are more energetic
events. Right? So the, the scale,
so it happens at Ligo is sensitive
to the human auditory range.
And that's just strange coincidence.
But these black holes about this size,
that's the natural frequency at which
they would emit gravitational waves.
But I think when they designed
the instrument, you know,
this has been going on for 50 years. They
were looking for Supernova. They were,
they were hoping to hear things like that.
So,
so it turns out that the Supernova might
be too quiet or too difficult and that
these are much more uh,
populous. And so, um,
but yes, if you send something
in space and there is a project,
it's done something into space,
millions of kilometers apart,
they would be way outside of the human
auditory range, way lower in frequency.
And they would be detecting things
like supermassive black holes colliding
bigger things and lower frequency stuff.
Yes.
Hi. I've had to have been to the
climbing black holes for them to kill us.
MMM. MMM. That's an
interesting question. Um,
it would be pretty hard to kill us with
gravitational waves. There are so weak,
it would be really hard like,
um,
to be squeezed and stretched like
you can you with your bare hands,
you could squeeze in,
stretch me billions of trillions of times
harder than a gravitational wave could.
So, um, I think, uh, it,
I'd be much more worried just about
being near the black holes generally.
So I'm, but black holes aren't really
the engines of destruction that they were
portrayed to be. A first son was
replaced with a black hole tomorrow. Uh,
we wouldn't sucked in
like a vacuum cleaner.
It would suck us in where we
would actually orbit just fine.
The orbit would be exactly the same.
It would be totally fine. I mean,
we'd be dead because it
would be cold and dark,
but we wouldn't fall in and we were
actually very slowly falling into a black
hole. Now there's a supermassive black
hole at the center of our galaxy 4 million
times the mass of the sun. And we are
in fact falling into that black hole.
It's going to take a very long time.
Very long time.
I really am worried about other things.
Yeah.
If you had an infinitely
sensitive detector,
where would you see
gravitational waves from?
Would it be from everything or is it just
everything? I would make
gravitational waves right now. Um,
infinitely sensitive
detector would, um, would,
would pick up gravitational waves from
all of us moving around and you'll be
moving.
You have to be moving.
So a black hole just sitting there is
not going to create gravitational waves.
And it's just a funny thing that if,
uh,
if like a star exploded perfectly
symmetrically in all directions,
it actually would not
create gravitational waves.
So you need a what's called a quadripolar
or a certain kind of asymmetry and
accelerations of masses. Yeah. But I'm,
I'm, I'm not spherically symmetric,
so I am making gravitational waves
above the one that I've been did.
They did,
I'm curious about what we knew about them,
their relative size,
the black holes. You mean
the one that we have? Yeah,
some what,
what can we knew about them?
Yeah,
it's pretty amazing.
So the details that we seem to be able
to extract as one was about 29 times the
mass of the sun to begin
with. One was over 30. Um,
by the time they collided,
they made a black hole,
maybe about 62 times the mass of the sun,
which means some of the energy that we
call e equals MC squared energy was he
admitted in the gravitational waves,
a few percent of the energy was
admitted in the gravitational waves.
And that's a tremendous amount of energy.
That's just a huge amount of energy.
Um, and that black hole is
out there right now spinning.
They think they know it's
spinning very rapidly,
probably hundreds of times a second.
We saw the last four orbits or sell.
So, but that we know the
location. Now, this black hole,
not very well, not very well.
It came from the southern sky.
Somewhere over there, they have
a map, a kind of splotchy map.
It sort of came from over there. It's 1.3
billion years away, right? To find it.
Um,
they can't find it anymore because
a telescope can't see a dark object.
And so what they could try to do is
pinpoint the galaxy that it lives in Egypt
and then that would tell it,
uh,
how something about the galaxy might
tell us something about the black holes.
Very surprised that they were that big.
That was something that surprised people.
I wasn't particularly surprised.
I work on this a lot and I, uh,
I never been had a prejudice
against big black holes,
but a lot of people did. They just thought
it will be hard to make them, but we,
the details of how to make black holes,
it's so hard.
I always thought we're probably not
write about a lot of that stuff. Um,
so this was real astronomical
information from the first detection.
It wasn't just we recorded
gravitational waves. It was,
we've discovered the first black hole
system and we've had discovered the first
collision of black holes and we know
things that we didn't know before. Cool.
Yeah, it's very cool. They're
very lucky. Very lucky. Yes.
What other
like gravitational wave detection
systems are coming online soon?
Yeah. So, um, there is this
one called [inaudible],
which is going to be underground and
that helps isolate at seismically. So,
so that will be helpful at some level.
The experiments are limited just by
quantum noise that there's nothing you can
do about quantum mechanics.
You know, quantum fluctuations,
if you've heard about tides
and bourbon certainty,
prince will makes it impossible at some,
in some regime they're working
on suppressing quantum effects,
but eventually they'll hit some
fundamental physical limit where,
where the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
says you can never precisely locate
an object on, they'll be up against that
limit with the mirrors. Right? It's just,
it doesn't exist in a precise enough the
location anymore. Um, technically. So,
um, but cargo will help with seismic
stuff. And so there is Virgo,
which is in Italy, which will hopefully
come online this summer as well. Um,
and then I mentioned the one in
India and, uh, there's Geo, um,
and I can't remember all of the others
right now. Tama I think is offline now,
but there's a whole network of
them eventually in space. Um,
that would be very exciting. Do you
mean just gravitational wave by the way?
Or any gravity experiments? Yeah, so,
so these are the ones, they're all of
the lego variety except the space born,
uh, Lisa, which would
put three spacecraft, uh,
disconnected millions of
kilometers apart from each other,
freely floating in space for
gravitational waves passes.
They all just Bob and they keep
track of each other with a laser to,
it's a really clever experiment.
There are some people who are
trying different ideas. Again,
going back to atomic clocks and
timing experiments, but I, you know,
they're are very new,
so it would be interesting to see if
anyone makes progress with that. Um,
we, uh, I put the clock at if
we're counting down to one,
but I think we could take one more
question if, if somebody wanted to. Yeah.
Or two more.
Yes.
So it's thinking about you, the earlier
question about the gravity waves.
So they were formed by the black holes.
They came by, they'd already tucked did.
And as they spread out,
they get weaker and weaker,
but so they don't really dissipate
because there's no friction.
So what happens to them?
They just keep going on.
Well, just imagine a light bulb, um,
up close is very bright and far away,
very dim,
and it's just cause you're
really intercepting less of
it to some extent, right?
And you're up close, you're
intercepting a whole lot of the light,
but it's very far away.
You're getting very little of it.
The rest went to other planets in
other galaxies and, and uh, you know,
the farther out it spreads,
the less any small patch
of sky is going to get.
Just like a light bulb
if they would ultimately
just keep going forever.
Yeah. Okay. And if the universe is
finite, they'll come back again.
Eventually we'll wrap around and
then they'll come back again.
We'll hear it a second time.
Even quieter.
The picture of the,
um, the wave showed up.
Vertical Axis frequency oscillating
around 20 hertz, I noticed. Yeah,
last 0.4 seconds.
Yeah.
Surely the two objects were actually
orbiting much faster than that. Right.
So how does that relate
to their actual orbital?
Um, it actually 20 hertz. Uh,
it also,
so the gravitational wave is
directly related to the orbital rate.
Um, uh, so if you think about that,
that's extremely fast,
right? 20 Hertz, um,
is really fast because you're talking
about something 200 kilometers,
traveling several hundred
kilometers and doing that orbit,
uh, many times a second. So it's
actually incredibly fast. Okay.
Um,
and so you are going near the speed of
light to be able to hit that frequency.
And that's how, uh, there was a previous
question about what sets the frequency.
That's sort of one way to think about it,
you know,
how far is it going in an
orbit and how fast is it going?
And that will set the frequency. Um, it's,
the gravitational wave is twice the
orbital frequency is their relationship.
Um, I think that's it. Thank you.
Thanks for.